I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her Oh
[Music]
Batman and Robin one word why guys
welcome back to a much overdue hilarious
'ti review now if you are a new reviewer
and you do not know what I mean by that
I have a segment on my channel in which
I review movies that are such atrocities
they're hilarious hilarious 'ti it's my
excuse to talk about really terrible
movies that are so bad they're funny
past examples have been the room The
Wicker Man the happening Mortal Kombat
annihilation and steal if you'd like to
see my reviews for those films the
playlist link is in the description
below but this one's gonna be a little
bit different because this film is so
intensely bad and so incredibly
hilarious that I had to have some help I
had to bring in the cavalry on this one
so I called one of my best friends and
Batman's superfan John flicking jerk or
the flick pic as you may know him him
and I are gonna be teaming up in this
video we're gonna go back-to-back I'm
gonna start talking about Batman and
Robin he's gonna bring you some awesome
points it's gonna be amazing we're gonna
tag-team this bitch let's talk about one
of the dumbest movies ever made Batman
and Robin
hey there guys my name is John I want to
say thanks to Chris stuckman for having
me here on this collab the Larry ostomy
review the unfortunate thing is it's for
Batman and Robin at first I was almost
hesitant to say yes why well at men I
had to watch Scooby Batman and Robin
again I want many many years in my life
without watching this movie for good
reason because every time I do watch it
makes me feel cold dark and icky inside
and I just hate everything about myself
but since we're both batman fanboys and
we love the character of batman maybe a
little bit too much
and also since we both hate this
atrocity against movies well I thought
I'd share my hate for the movie as well
so let's dive into it all that being
said this movie actually does have some
fans though this movie is largely viewed
as good by people who basically view it
as a continuation of the Adam West
Batman now I grew up watching the
original Batman show it was hilarious
and a lot of people just view this movie
as a straight-up comedy as if it's
supposed to be but if you watch Batman
Forever which is also directed by Joel
Schumacher you know this movie really is
actually a sequel to Batman Forever it's
not a sequel to Adam West's Batman
even though it really does feel like
that at times this movie is so bad that
almost everyone involved with it has
publicly apologized for it including the
director himself if there's anybody
watching this that lets say loved Batman
Forever and went into Batman or Robin
with great anticipation if I if I
disappointed them in any way then I
really want to apologize because it
wasn't my intention my intention was
just entertaining them and there is very
strong compelling evidence that this
movie was just made to sell toys that's
why every poison ivy action comes
complete when him
in fact there is proof that toy
companies wanted them to include certain
vehicles and certain outfits in the
movie so they could then make a toy of
that outfit or vehicle and profit also
on a very sad and unfortunate no this is
Bob Kane's last Batman film that he saw
the creator of the Batman character sad
indeed so right off the bat and the
first scene in which Batman and Robin
are suiting up you get a few shots that
indicate the type of movie you're about
to see what in the hell were they
thinking
but shots I mean can you just see Joel
Schumacher behind the camera going okay
now now tilt the camera at a Dutch angle
okay now Clooney's stunt double please
turn around and hop towards the camera
with your butt in frame and then
cameraman please please zoom in on his
butt please do that because that's
that's what this scene needs this scene
needs a butt zoom
alright so Batman and Robin let's
pretend like you've never seen this
movie before so you sit down to watch
the movie you're a little bit excited a
little bit scared and the first thing
you see pop up on the screen is
rubberized man asses close-ups that's
what sets the tone for this movie
close-ups of man asses thanks Joel
Schumacher you really set the tone for
this movie and the tone is ass and then
after a short montage of man asses the
movie opens up in the Batcave and you
get your first glimpse at the Batmobile
now I've always been a huge fan of the
Batmobile it's something I've always
wanted my entire life you give me a
billion dollars that's the first thing
I'm going to buy but I'll never buy the
Batmobile from Batman and Robin just
look at this neon nightmare it looks
like a futuristic sex toy just from a
few quick shots you get to see if the
Batcave you have to ask yourself
something how much of this film's budget
went to fluorescent light bulbs and of
course we cannot go without mentioning
that the suits are anatomically correct
in every way including nipples now there
was some subtle nip egde on Val Kilmer's
bat suit in Batman Forever it was a
little subtle nip egde it was like they
tried to sneak a little nip this year
they were
to sneak that nip and movie made a lot
of money and so they're like okay let's
go a full-fledged nip let's do a circle
and then the actual nip we'll put it on
the suit with bat and Robin nips that's
what we need we need bat nips and they
did it it was in a movie like we sat in
a theater and the camera pans up Batman
and there's large purr truce have back
nipples
it happened on earth this movie happened
on planet earth now please observe the
first exchange of dialogue in this movie
I want a car chicks dig the car this is
why Superman works alone
I want a car chicks dig the car shut up
Robin oh and by the way if you're Alfred
do yourself a favor and do not order
pizza because Batman and Robin are gonna
be busy don't order pizza I'll kind of
pull the pizza and that's Batman and
Robin drive away we get the most obvious
oh my god Alfred is sick shot I mean
seriously look how long it lingers on it
[Music]
[Applause]
now here's something that not a lot of
people actually talk about for some
reason this scene always confuses me
first off
Commissioner Gordon pops up and gives us
a ton of Mr Freeze exposition Batman a
new villain has commandeered the Gotham
museum he's frozen the antiquities wing
he's president security guards into
blocks of ice he's calling himself mr.
freeze mr. freeze he acts as if mr.
freeze is new and unheard of but
Batman's reply is mr. freeze like he
knows who mr. freeze is but Commissioner
Gordon said he's new I don't get it it's
such a small little point but it's
bugged me for years so we're now
introduced to Arnold Schwarzenegger as
mr. freeze one of the dumbest casting
choices ever I mean seriously this is
the Terminator okay his next villain
role after the Terminator is mr. freeze
in Batman and Robin we've gone down my
friends now it's time to dive into the
really really bad stuff some could even
call it chilling now I love Arnold but
ask Mr Freeze it just didn't quite work
out within the first 9 seconds of being
introduced to the character of mr.
freeze he gives two puns about ice and
don't worry there's about 2,000 more
coming over the next two hours of this
movie you are not sending me to the
cooler what killed the dinosaurs cool
party now I did do a Batman and Robin
review in the past with my buddies the
schmoes and you may have remembered in
that review that I talked about the fact
that every single Batman
has an amazing way of saying I'm Batman
from Michael Keaton to Val Kilmer to
Christian Bale they all did a very cool
Batman speech in which they said who
they are here's a look back at those I'm
Batman because I choose to be
now please observe George Clooney's
attempt at saying who he is I freeze I'm
Batman I freeze I'm Batman
it's like he's talking to a guy at the
mall hey I'm Batman good for you man
you're fucking psycho I freeze I'm
Batman
and I thought my jokes were bad and of
course after his introduction he slides
down a dinosaur tail and every time I
see it this is what I think of hey
freeze I'm Batman
and it's at that point you realize that
George Clooney is not Batman he's not
Bruce Wayne
he's just George Clooney and a
rubberised Batman suit with nipples
that's all you're getting here yeah the
rubber nipples on the bat suit two
reasons to never watch this movie reason
number one and the reason number two and
by the way on a side note I like George
Clooney as an actor but as Batman
he was just miscast as was everyone in
this movie and even George Clooney will
agree that his role as Batman just
didn't make any sense whatsoever just be
shots of me in a rubber suit and a
Batman outfit
for your consideration ass now let's
continue on talking about this opening
action sequence and just how bloated and
bad it really is so you have zombie
hockey players skating around and then
all the sudden Batman and Robin are
laying on their backs and then Batman to
rob and click their heels together and
now come ice skates yeah they have
built-in ice skates in their boots
because why the hell not it's Batman and
Robin anything goes and I'll be honest
with you it was at this point in the
movie for the last 17 years I've shut
the movie off every time I'm just like
that's too much I can't take it any
longer but this time I kept going and it
hurt but I kind of liked it and when you
conclusively break down this opening
action sequence and Batman and Robin it
comes across like a bad cruise ship on
Ice Show featuring Batman
except that shitty cruise ship show with
Batman on ice skating around would be
more compelling and better acted
probably the better stunt work to not a
lot of people notice this next moment
because it's kind of in the background
but I've unfortunately had the pleasure
I guess you could call it that of
examining Batman and Robin from
beginning to end in preparation for this
review when Robin launches through the
wall his motorcycle actually creates the
Robin symbol this never gets a close-up
because I'm pretty sure the filmmakers
realized how stupid that is but if you
look in the background you can see it
now throughout this scene there are some
mind-blowing displays of physics in
action or lack thereof
now after freeze gets into his rocket
ship and blasts into the air he seems to
reveal that he has an odd sexual fetish
for switches
[Music]
who turns a switch like that I mean when
you walk into your room and you turn on
your light you go oh yes no you don't no
one does that ever just mr. freeze
but unfortunately the scene doesn't end
there it keeps going and going at one
point mr. freeze runs over to his
getaway mobile it turns into a
rocketship
he shoots up into the sky and then some
things happen and then he jumps out of
that to turn into a mr. freeze butterfly
and you just have to ask yourself two
things one why does mr. freeze have a
rocketship and two why did he turn into
a butterfly I don't know now of course
at the end of this scene Batman and
Robin escaped the exploding ship by
surfing on air on pieces of the door in
just like the first 10 minutes of this
movie
we've got butt shots nips surfing on air
mr. freeze and his crazy Arnold
Schwarzenegger isms and physics this
movie jumped the shark like 50 times
already and then a few seconds later
Batman or Robin confront mr. freeze and
Robin gets frozen after trying to make a
heroic failed attempt to stop him by the
way if you really break down this scene
and you look at Robin jumping at mr.
freeze he would have only jumped about
three feet and mr. freeze was like 25
feet away so what was Robin thinking oh
we've only covered opening scenes so far
this movie's two hours long
most comedies are only supposed to be an
hour and a half let's just keep going so
if you're already in pain at the
portrayal of mr. freeze we now get the
most purposefully over-the-top
poison ivy they could have done I mean
they're going for it you know there
isn't like an accident here
Uma Thurman's portrayal of poison ivy is
so hilariously over-the-top I mean it's
exploding over the brim then of course
there's Bane or should I say
Frankenstein because he's just some
strange green thing created in a lab by
a crazy mad scientist for the purpose of
selling him to some weird place who
wants to buy green people
who are made I'm just gonna skip talking
about bane because I know John wants to
delve into this because he's a massive
Bane fan so I'm just gonna let him talk
about Bane now if you thought this movie
couldn't possibly get any worse while I
assure you it does next up we're talking
about the introduction of the characters
of poison ivy and Bane oh fuck that
thing that they call Bane in this movie
that's not Bane that's a big bloated
green veiny pickle jacked up on steroids
who just randomly mumbles words we've
got work to do that's not Bane and then
you have the character of poison ivy
play by uma Thurman and poison ivy in
this movie was probably the most
over-the-top character of the entire
film and that's really saying something
because yeah Mr Freeze is also in this
film but at times it's like uma Thurman
thought she was in some live-action porn
about plants and you're like this chick
really likes plants maybe a little bit
too much but the best worst part about
this introduction scene to Bane and
poison ivy is when the mad scientist
confronts uma thurman's character and he
gives a line the only Nicolas Cage could
get away with saying well in that case
I'm afraid you'll have to die I'm afraid
you'll have to die and then he pushes
her over a table and she turns into
poison ivy how climactic but all
fairness to Huma Thurman I'm pretty sure
she was just following the vision of
director Joel Schumacher and that vision
was to do whatever the hell producers
told him to do so they could sell some
more toys and look over their kids
there's rubberband nipples suckle knows
because I don't give a fuck about Batman
you're watching Batman or Robin a
two-hour long toy commercial you better
like it and buy some toys while you're
at it and by the way on a side note this
scene also shows two of the same clips
of Bane flexing yeah right here and
right here same clip used twice so now
we get more mr. freeze exposition in
which Bruce and dick and Alfred they all
watched security camera footage of how
he became mr. freeze of course this
security camera footage is filmed like a
movie complete with pans and
and sound so poison ivy gets created
she actually literally sprouts from the
ground and then all of a sudden she
seems to know exactly what has happened
to her body and if he didn't already
understand the direction this movie was
going next there's a scene in which
Arnold Schwarzenegger as mr. freeze
tries to conduct his various cronies to
sing along with him this scene also
contains some of the worst dubbing I've
seen in a big-budget film it's 1 to 5 of
Gotham it's winter forever here in
Gotham and for whatever reason the
writers thought we needed even more
characters in this movie so we have
Alicia Silverstone as Batgirl because
apparently we needed Batgirl in this
movie but she's not Barbara Gordon as
she is in the comics she's Barbara
Wilson and for whatever reason
apparently Alfred is her uncle now I
know that the writers are just looking
for a convenient reason for her to show
up on Wayne manors doorstep and that's
all they could think of and it's so
annoying that they couldn't just just
just have her be Barbara Gordon just
could you just give us that one little
thing that's like the comics just that
one thing also starring in Batman and
Robin as an actress who hasn't been
relevant since the 1990s Alicia
Silverstone and you have to ask yourself
this why would they cast clueless as
Batgirl but then again why would you
cast George Clooney as Batman nothing
makes sense but speaking of Alicia
Silverstone on a positive note she
probably has the most subtle performance
in this entire film yeah compare her to
Emma Thurman's character poison ivy
she's almost giving an oscar-worthy
performance at times if you make the
comparison hits around this point in the
movie where you realized they're really
not gonna attempt to flesh out Bruce
Wayne's character at all he wanders
around he goes to rich banquets and
auctions and he says things and goes
like this I'm George Clooney good night
I'm Batman hey freeze I'm Batman that's
my George Clooney Batman impression
there really are no attempts to flesh
out Bruce Wayne as a character in this
movie we just get real
awkward pauses you see the major issue
with George Clooney's portrayal as
Batman which could have been in the
writing or his direction as well is the
fact that he plays the same character in
all three of Bruce's roles now a good
Batman has three characters that's Bruce
Wayne as he is in the public eye a
playboy asshole that's Bruce Wayne as he
actually is in the Batcave with Alfred
and Batman three different characters he
plays the same character no matter what
in this movie all right guys let's talk
about the auction scene yeah the auction
scene now they try to make this scene
make sense by adding some brief little
exchange between Batman and Robin in
which they say essentially that they're
trying to bait Mr Freeze by having all
these jewels cuz Mr Freeze needs in to
power his suit or whatever but it's
really just obvious that Schumacher is
trying to have another circus scene he
really wants Batman to be a fucking
circus that's all he wants big shiny
lights and circus and Men and their
little outfits and fucking gorillas and
what the fuck are you doing with this
movie Schumacher this is Batman not
nipply circus action man now as stated I
rewatched this movie in preparation for
this review I did so with my wife
because she said I will take it with you
we'll do it together we'll tackle it I
was like you're the best I love you and
when it got to this scene with the
fucking gorilla she said and I'll never
forget it she's wet I don't really
understand what's going on here
that's how everyone felt at that moment
and through the majority in this movie's
runtime now in poison ivy shows herself
a whole bunch of shirtless men with
glitter on their chests catch her yes
this is a Batman movie I feel the need
to continuously reiterate this is a
Batman movie and her awesome
entrance line is this why not send
junior home early I've got some Wild
Oats to sow well you better get going to
sow those oats poison ivy cuz you gotta
get those oats sowed now it's at this
point in the film we come to the charity
auction scene and this is where poison
ivy becomes a full-fledged porn star
just listen to some of the shit that she
says my garden needs tending some lucky
boys about to hit the honey pot I bring
everything you see Plus everything you
don't what a whore now listen as a dude
I don't really mind some of those
one-liners they're a little bit exciting
at times but they just feel like they'd
be in a video that you would come across
on pornhub calm that would also a Batman
in it by the way if you look hard enough
you can actually find that video I
guarantee it so she starts to blow her
mist around and it makes everyone
infatuated with her and everyone starts
to bid for her including Batman and
Robin they're going back and forth
millions and millions of dollars and you
guys know exactly what I'm getting at
Batman has a credit card seven minutes
never leave the cave without it and if
you look real closely you'll notice it's
good for ever and it's at that point in
the movie I once again questioned why I
am watching this and when I actually
watched this movie to take notes for
this video I turn it off right there I
went outside I screamed up at the moon
and then I came back in and finished the
movie and then after that a few seconds
later mr. freeze breaks in the door and
says cool potty and I think that's his
87th I spun of the movie at this point
and he starts freezing people and then
once all the chaos settles down and
there's a lot of frozen people in the
background Batman casually walks by
Commissioner Gordon and says you have 11
minutes with all these people out and
then he just takes off up the door after
mr. freeze
Commissioner you have 11 minutes to
follow these people well thanks Batman
thanks for all the help I don't have a
special bat laser like you had our
convenient pool water to put these
frozen people and so how the hell is
Commissioner Gordon supposed to all
these people out in 11 minutes it's like
thanks Batman can I maybe borrow some of
your handy gadgets to save these
people's lives I mean you have ice
skates built into your boots can I
borrow one of your extra lasers no
you're just gonna leave well fuck you
too yeah I think it's safe to assume all
those people frozen in that scene died
they're dead because of Batman
apparently mr. Freeze's exit cue was a
random guy falling in front of him
that's my exit cue he really planned
this attack very well he knew exactly
when to lead he was like when the random
guy who falls in front of you the owl
when you fall down it's my executor and
I gotta bring up the jumping physics the
absurd physics in this movie what were
they thinking everyone in this movie
looks like they're wearing a wire that
just propels them into the air at will
so as they chase mr. freeze it goes
outside Batman catches mr. freeze now
please observe how he does this
[Music]
is Batman in this moment breaking the
fourth wall is he actually like hey
audience watching look at mr. freeze I
caught him did Batman put mr. freeze on
the ground then cover him up with his
cape only to pull up set cape and go
look what I did I shot makes no sense
guys so now we get a random Jesse
Ventura cameo which only makes me wish I
was watching predator and for whatever
reason that filmmakers thought every 30
minutes or so they should have some
random relationship drama with a girl
who has the most obvious audio dubbed
voice since Arnold Schwarzenegger 20
minutes ago in the same movie I know
you're a dedicated bachelor Batman
captures mr. freeze putting him in
Arkham Asylum and then the next scene
you see mr. freeze in a refrigerator
being wheeled down the hallways of
Arkham now it's bad enough when watching
this movie and having to deal with all
mr. Freeze's corny punny one-liners
related to ice but in this scene even
the jail guards are joining in on it
welcome and then mr. freeze has to
one-up them both by saying allow me to
break the ice
I'm freeze and it's just like it's like
they already know that mr. freeze that's
why they're making jokes of that cold
shit and let's get back to Alicia
Silverstone that's right she's still in
the movie and she lives a double life by
racing motorcycles at night to earn a
little bit of extra cash to pay back her
uncle Alfred which by the way Alfred in
this movie is dying did I mention that
before it's a subplot it doesn't really
matter so during this bike racing scene
it really reminds me of a scene that you
would see out of the movie the warriors
that came out in the 1970s you have all
these flamboyant gangs dressed like
clowns just standing around and of
course what's a Batman movie without
Coolio this is the guy who sang the
Kenan & Kel theme song right around then
he was pretty popular and I guess they
thought hey we'll put him in the movie
because he's Coolio and he should be in
our Batman film that Bob Kane saw and
then he passed away
oh that's bad and can we please talk
about the green screen in this scene
with Batgirl hanging what in hell were
they thinking now in the background
they're clearly using a green screen and
then in the foreground they're shooting
it with a camera but both things are
shaking at different variations like
somebody took the green screen footage
and shook that and during the filming of
the scene someone shook that but neither
shapes line up so both things are going
back and forth like that and you're like
what is happening here how is this it
almost looks like an earthquake is
taking place during the scene so then a
few minutes later Bain and Ivy break
mister freeze out of Arkham Asylum and
it's during the scene where poison ivy
gives one of the best lines I've ever
heard in my entire life this is one of
those lines where you can tell that the
writer really sat down for days and you
know use pure integrity and creativeness
to come up with it and not including
this line in a feature-length film would
be a crime against cinema rocks yeah
poison ivy is just a porn star in this
movie that's all she is a porn star with
a plant fetish so Ivy and freeze team-up
big whoop it he do who cares you all
knew it was happening why else would
they be in the movie if not to team up
in some way now as you guys know one of
the coolest parts of Batman in the
comics and in the better Batman films is
that Batman is a detective this is
something that the original animated
series nailed now here is the film's
only attempt at showing Batman as a
detective poison-ivy why would she help
freeze escape oh she's definitely evil
now let's quickly talk about a random
scene in this movie that's always just
bothered me for some odd reason at one
point in this movie Commissioner Gordon
is doing some actual police work for the
first time ever and he's showing Batman
a few pictures of poison ivy and Bane in
one picture they're breaking mr. freeze
out of Arkham and the other picture
they're arriving at an airport now let's
take a closer look at this picture of
Bane and poison ivy at the airport first
of all this airport looks like some
stock photo of an airport from 1949 they
terribly photoshopped Baden poison ivy
into the picture and look at their
disguises look how not discreet they're
being look at that Bane's wearing a
trench coat and poison ivy just looks
like she's up to something nice to sky
guys but it's not the pictures that
bother me about the scene it's what
Batman says after he sees the pictures
it's definitely the same pair that
spring freeze well no shit Batman who
else could it be there's a big bloated
guy in a trench coat and some sexy
seductive plant fetish porn star and the
other one how could you ever not think
it was the same people in both pictures
thanks Captain Obvious I thought you
were master detective no you're just
George Clooney with rubber nipples so
Batman and Robin and Bane have what
could be a really epic fight scene but
is really just them punching each other
once or twice and then throw it in a
really terrible pun there might as well
be big POW and Kabam words just
appearing above them
now it's a few minutes later on in the
movie where you finally get to see the
big epic showdown go down Batman versus
Bane and as a kid who loved Bane from
the comic books this was something I
always wanted to see go down in a
live-action movie and then this happened
and this fight scene between Batman and
Bane isn't good to say the least
and it's interrupted every four seconds
by poison ivy two spewing out some corny
one-liner
it just keeps cutting back and forth
between them fighting and poison ivy say
random dumb shit about plants oh yeah
let's get back to the Batman vs. Bane
fight scene or if you want to call it a
fight scene it's pretty much as these
two guys stumbling over each other then
all the sudden Bane punches a snowman
and falls into some boxes what an epic
conclusion to that showdown now it's at
this point in the movie where they
finally unveil mr. freeze and Poison
Ivy's master plan and here's what their
plan is mr. freeze wants to blanket the
entire planet in ice and poison ivy
wants to repopulate the earth with her
Little Shop of Horrors they have mouths
and I have a question
don't plants need sunlight and warmth to
grow so how is this plan ever going to
coincide with one another how did they
not logistically think about this plant
not working whatsoever with one another
but yet they team up to do it anyway now
let's continue on with a few other small
details that I've always just bothered
me about the movie Batman and Robin now
in this scene we're talking about Batman
or Robin
infiltrate mr. Freeze's hideout they go
into his freezer room where he keeps all
his frozen TV dinners and they slide
back one and behind this is a hidden
button but the button is the size of an
iPad and is glowing blue now you would
think if they went through all that
trouble to hide this button which opens
up a secret passageway they maybe would
have made the button a little bit
smaller a little bit more discreet now
let's just make it as big as an iPad and
make it glow blue it's like why would
you go through all the trouble even
hiding it in the first place I guess
over embellishing everything is the
theme of this movie then during this
same scene Mr Freeze is actually
sneaking around his hideout and then he
jumps out into a room of police officers
pulling a lever unleashing the freeze
mist now let's take a closer look at
what's actually happening here if you
pay close attention the fog is barely
touching
half of the police officers and the guy
in the background sign even being
affected whatsoever he can just walk
away and be completely okay why is he
coughing why is he choking and everyone
else that's actually in the fog miss can
walk one step forward and be completely
okay it's almost like they started
filming the scene before they could
completely fog up the room to make it
look logical or get another fog machine
in there and make it happen quicker but
it's Batman and Robin why do things that
make sense and the way Batgirl discovers
Batman and Robin's secret identity is so
stupid with the images projected
directly onto her face from a computer
computer screens do not reflect perfect
projected images onto your face like
that
speaking of computer things that don't
make any sense
Batgirl discovers that Alfred has used
his brain algorithms to create a
consciousness that is able to interact
with Batgirl and provide her with a
Batgirl costume suit we have uncle
Alfred
[Music]
I'm done okay I'm getting a little bit
tired let's jump towards the end of this
movie and quickly mention this scene
right here hi oh I'm sorry about the
door is the party over yeah only Arnold
can pull off something like that any
other actor trying to do that it
wouldn't be as funny are comedic so
Arnold I love the guy but Mr Freeze use
fool and speaking of charismatic
one-liners a few seconds later we get
this scene right here from Bane
[Music]
bom-bom-bom thanks for that great scene
Bing tard now go eat some applesauce
all right let's dive deeper into the
ending of this turd at the very end of
the movie you have Batman Batgirl and
Robin they all have new costumes to
obviously sell more toys and then all of
a sudden yeah how did Alicia Silverstone
become Batgirl so quick within 30
seconds she becomes bad girl I guess no
special training is required because
soon as you put on the Batgirl suit
you're instantly a superhero so now we
get a scene where Robin gets the upper
hand on Ivy's poisonous kiss and he says
one of the film's most hilarious lines
that was written by a person rubber lips
are immune to your charms and the film
took it so seriously to the scene it's
like this big epic moment you might as
well it's been like my nipples are hard
right now poison ivy what do you think
about that
so now bad girls in on the action she's
fighting poison ivy and please take note
of this shot because you need to
remember that for later an IV is somehow
defeated by one of her babies I don't
know how that even happened but it just
did I guess that plant was just like
fuck this bitch I'm sick of this shit
man these people tell me what to do
Isaac up is gonna eat her that's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna eat her
apparently that plant with samuel
l.jackson I don't know where that
impression came from and you are that
girl that's not lovely PC what about
that person or that woman
that's not awfully politically correct
how about butt shots and bat nipples for
PC so the big finale starts and my one
question is where in the hell did they
get their new costumes did they go back
to the Batcave and change them these
costumes that were made specifically to
sell toys now please observe how awful
batgirls cowl looks in fact it's so bad
it's almost like they were just making
it up as they went along because like 30
seconds later she takes it off and
throws it on the ground
it's literally like she Ward that awful
cowl just so they could have a
another Batgirl action figure with said
cowl on within a minute later they're
like this thing looks like shit
throw it on the ground and then after
that you see all three heroes driving
separate vehicles to the final location
of the film and the only reason they're
all driving separately to the exact same
location as well they wanted to sell
some more fucking toys and then finally
the big action blow to climax goes down
and it's just atrocious to look at you
have all these actors dangling on wires
doing way too many flips you're like is
this an acrobatic stunts show or a
Batman movie nothing looks good it's all
cringe-worthy and speaking of
cringe-worthy the scene that happens
during all this is where Bane finally
gets defeated yeah they ripped the venom
out of him and he starts to shrink back
down and I can't even describe how funny
it is just watch it yeah Bane lost all
his games and that moon was just
glorious and then after that shit gets
really bad you have Batman along with
two of their scientists falling to their
deaths on the side of this clip and
during all this Robin a bad girl are
looking on
and Batgirl looks to Robin and says what
should we do now and Robin says pray
what did you just say Robin you're the
superhero sidekick to Batman and you
said let's just pray how about you take
out your grappling hook and shoot it
towards batman to help save his life
that's what you have it for and Batman
being the badass that he is he saves the
day all on his own by shooting his
grappling hooks into the sky and
stopping everyone from falling but
instead of taking the scientists back to
the top of the cliff where they're safe
and secure he leaves the boat on the
side of this icy cold cliff where
they're surely going to die of
hypothermia within the next 10 minutes
this is one of those movies where
characters say things really quickly and
fast so you hopefully won't realize how
dumb it is like relaying sunlight from
the Congo using satellites to create a
light beam to melt the city of Gotham
yes things like that it's unlike you to
reverse the freezing process for five
hours here but it's
in the Congo if we could relay the
sunlight from the other side of the
Equator take the satellites about a
minute to realign but and Mr Freeze and
Batman have their big epic fight and it
ends with Batman saying some big line
supposed to be incredibly epic now
Batman films in the past have said
things like this and they've worked
quite a bit let's take a look at George
Clooney's epic Batman line
they breathe the heat is on oh hey
freeze the heat is on now if you recall
earlier I said remember that shot of
poison ivy
that's because Batman uses it as if he
recorded it or something his show mr.
freeze that IV actually killed his wife
but it's the same shot as earlier this
movie constantly uses security camera
footage or footage recorded by someone
and it's a fucking movie shot with
production and everything now of course
mr. freeze has the cure for Alfred's
disease and his IV even has a perfect
slot tailor-made for mr. Freeze's vile
and of course Alfred is perfectly fine
the following morning thank goodness we
didn't get another one of these things
now let's talk about the last shot in
this movie it's one of the scariest
things I've ever seen in my life and
I'll explain what I'm talking about in
just a second but the last shot is
Batman Robin and Batgirl running at the
camera in slow motion with a spotlight
behind them as if to get us excited for
a third movie who would want to see all
that come together here's the really
scary thing think about this if this
movie was successful and made the money
that they wanted it to make and people
actually liked it you would have had
that third installment directed by Joel
Schumacher how all right so that's my
take on Batman Robin probably one of the
worst movies ever made and without a
doubt the worst comic book movie ever
made or at least to me it was this
movie's just cringe-worthy bloated
nothingness it's basically a two-hour
toy commercial except toy commercials
have better acting and better directing
in them and there's not one redeeming
quality about this entire movie now you
could say it's so bad at times it's
funny but the truth is the only reason
we're laughing is to keep from crying
because this is by far the worst Batman
movie ever made
but on a positive note had it not been
for this abomination against humanity
known as Batman and Robin well we never
would've got the rebooted Batman Begins
they would just continue down the road
with shitty Batman movies because they
make money and sell toys but this one
didn't quite live up to what they wanted
it to hey look if there's one thing we
have this movie to thank for its that
people were so awestruck by how bad
Batman could actually be that we got
Batman Begins so thank goodness for that
guys I hope you enjoyed this hilarious T
review and I really want to thank my
buddy John Flickinger the flick pick
without him this could not have been
nearly as awesome definitely subscribed
to him this guy is awesome he's one of
my best friends he makes quality
entertainment and just look at those
muscles I mean just look at those
muscles just wrap some baby oil on those
things man you can find a link for his
channel in the description below as well
as a link to my other hilarious 'ti
reviews in playlist form as mentioned
earlier so that's everything I had to
say about Batman and Robin and once
again thanks to my good pal Chris
Tuchman for having me here to share my
thoughts and my hate towards this movie
it felt really good I feel a little bit
better about Who I am what I'm doing in
life now so anyway yeah thanks for
having me here and thanks for watching
guys guys thank you so much as always
for watching I look forward to doing
more of these very soon and I apologize
I haven't done too many for a while
thank you so much guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck menage five freeze I'm Batman No
[Music]